before we see what was the point of all
of this can we get some agreement on a
number wolf number on pate here we've
got the divisor of 8 gives you a divot
no sorry a quotient of 42 and a
remainder of 5 are you happy with that
look at ok sir TOPAS okay and then here
we have a question of x squared minus 2x
minus 4 and then here's our remainder
down here negative 6 happy with that so
one of the ways that you can check and I
know I was really glad a lot of you did
this right is by taking this division
and actually writing it in terms of a
multiplication which is actually kind of
the main point for where we're going
here and we can do this for both of them
drains already hopefully done this right
when you've got your original your
dividend it is the divisor multiplied by
the question plus the remainder and you
can actually check that out what is 42
times 8 8 lots of 40 is 328 lots of 2 is
16 so 336 plus 5 does that give us 341
thumbs up it does right we haven't quite
written it here so let's do it now the
actual statement including
multiplication would be like this the
original thing we got here X cubed
takeaway 4x squared plus 2 right and
there is a zero extent but I only write
0x to help me do the division once I've
done that I don't need to write anymore
okay
what I'm saying is it's the divisor
there it is multiplied by the quotient
which is that thing at the top x squared
minus 2x minus 4 and then you add that
remainder on which in this case is
negative so I'm going to say take away 6
and we can just quickly do a check on
this right if you expanded this guy it
does look a little bit gross but it's
not impossible and maybe you want to
check this it's actually always good to
know how to check it so I'm gonna
multiply everything through by X which
gives me that then I'm going to multiply
everything through by negative 2 which
gives me this by the way you might
notice I'm writing on two lines in a
very deliberate way and I'll ask you in
a second why I've
that's a plus +8 and then there's the
minus six can anyone tell me why I've
written in this weird way not on one
line you know right it's to help me just
like in the long division right we sort
of arranged things to get the cubes
together the Squared's together the
single X's together and then the numbers
and I've done the same thing here I know
there's just a single X cubed which is
what I was hoping for
how many x squared terms do I get out of
this you can seem paired up right yeah
do I get minus 4x squared thumbs up what
happens to the X terms they cancel out
which is exactly what I was hoping for
cuz there are no X terms yeah and then 8
take away 6 thumbs up - is that me you
nevermind okay so this line here this
bottom one right is actually the one I'm
really focusing on what honest it is -
generalizes and I've been using these
language these terms very deliberately
okay we start with our original
polynomial what did I call it again the
thing that's being divided it's called
the the dividend okay so I'm gonna call
this the dividend function right now
we've been in function notation we'll be
using the we've been used to calling
things f of X or G of X or whatever of X
and they're just abbreviations right but
the reason why I'm calling this by its
full name is because I can't call it D
because I'm about to have something else
that is also starting with the day so
I'm giving the full name okay the
dividend is equal to mmm what we got
here that's the divisor and it's
multiplied by the quotient I'm gonna
have to rub off these ifs
[Music]
like so and then one more thing I'm
gonna add on through main done now this
is a funny thing
actually I'm not sure if we've dealt
with some questions like this yet but so
far in these kinds of questions here the
simple ones write the remainder you
might notice is just the number it's
just the number have we divided by any
quadratic factors yet we have so we know
then or we might might be good to
remember that if we divide by more
complicated functions if our divisor
there it is is like an x squared or
something like that okay then you're
room
down here might not just be a number it
might have some X's in it in other words
the remainder itself is also a function
can you write that light and line down
for me it's really important okay this
is the what the division transformation
gives us is the result right it's the
same thing that we saw Jermaine right
here with the numbers that relationship
this times this Plus this the remaining
bit left over this is what we can see
here okay now I'm going to take this and
write it in sort of a now in an
abbreviated form okay because I don't
really want to write all these long
words every single time okay usually
that the polynomial we originally start
with because it's a polynomial it tends
to be called P now you can see why I
didn't write that the first time because
it's a specific thing it's the thing
that's being divided
it's the dividend but we will just go
with this convention of calling it p4
polynomial okay we tend to the most
frequent thing we divide by is this kind
of linear factor like this it's we call
it linear because if we graphed it it'd
be a straight line right so it's gonna
be X take away or add something right so
I'm going to say X take away a you might
think why not X plus a I'm gonna come to
that in a minute but for now I'm gonna
make this my divisor it's not always
going to look like that but so
frequently this is the thing kind of
thing we divide by I'm gonna put that
out the front so that's the defines on
okay the question thankfully I have
nothing else that starts with Q so I'm
gonna call this quotient Q of X and then
lastly I've got my remainder hanging
around and I'm also going to abbreviate
that guy as well as no guesses for no
prizes for guessing our X okay now this
line here I didn't want to start with it
because it's like ah it's just death by
algebra this is what I really mean but
this is a lot more context to read okay
now why have I bothered to write it in
this form here's why sometimes and I'm
gonna get to this this sometimes like
what sometimes is it sometimes I don't
want to go through this whole long
process sometimes I'm not even
interested in this air to here sometimes
all I want to know is what's left over
sometimes the thing that is of
most value to me the question I'm most
interested in answering is what is this
remainder okay now if the remainder is
the thing we're focusing on this guy
over here right then there is actually
something in this line which makes it
really easy to directly go like go
straight to this remainder without going
through any of this division and as you
can see it's like a very error-prone and
long process it's called long division
for pizza right so if I can avoid this
that would be really nice here's the
really sneaky thing I'm going to do if
what I want is just this guy right then
I want to get rid of all of this see
that that's what I want to get rid of
now don't forget these are all functions
right functions so I can put values of X
into there what value might be helpful
what value of x could I substitute in
that would make this entire thing just
disappear if I put in x equals a because
what would happen right as soon as I
replace all of these X's with A's this
part here would become a takeaway which
is zero right so let's actually write
this if I substitute x equals a if I
substitute x equals a right then on this
next line I'm going to replace every X
of which I say one two three four I'm
gonna place them all with a z' I get
this p of a equals okay let's see here a
takeaway a queue of a plus R okay okay
now we just said the reason why we've
randomly chose that no but you can
really choose any number you like but
the reason why this is useful is because
now this thing here is just going to
disappear into thin air so kind of my
summary is P of a is just going to be
equal to after this disappears just the
remainder just that part on its own and
I'm gonna point out as well if we are
dividing by a linear guy like this right
the remainder is actually always going
to be just the number like all of the
early ones who try it out you didn't get
any X's flying around he just got like
three or negative 6 or two right
so you can see here in one fell swoop
without doing any division we can go
stretch the meter
watch let's test it out right what would
be VA for this particular question that
we just tried out have a look I'm
dividing my divisor looks like X minus a
so my a here is that number 2 do you see
that let's just give this a go let's see
what happens with this guy right my P of
X this is an example sorry in this case
over here is I'm defining it as X cubed
take away 4 x squared plus 2 okay so I'm
gonna try this thing yeah I'm gonna say
what's P of in this case my a is 2
that's what you just told me P of 2 okay
let's throw it in I'm gonna do my
substitution say yeah now the a is just
that number that I'm doing X - you told
me X - 2
the a is just the 2 does that make sense
so that's what I'm actually in a
substitution and you'll see what happens
when we give this a go 2 cubed I'm just
going to do a substitution step I'm not
gonna do any fancy actual evaluation
here that's just replacing all of my
exes with 2 you guys can tell me what 2
cubed is it's 8 and this is a bit more
messy yeah - 4 times 4 which is minus 16
and then plus 2 8 take away 16 is
negative 8 plus 2 new at you and you are
adding your eights and your teaser okay
so so look right what have we got here
we've gone directly to this final thing
without ever having to go through all of
that long division if it just so
happened that this is the thing I really
wanted then this I would argue is a much
faster way to go about it than doing a
lot of agent now because this thing is
all about the remainder right that P of
a whatever gives you the remainder right
we call this very original name the
remainder theorem right if what we were
searching for was just the remainder
right and I'm about to show you why this
is useful right if all we were thinking
of was just the remainder then this is
the fastest way to go there no
vision necessary that's a real relief
okay